foreign
what's up Diane
hello thank you for taking my call of
course doing okay
okay I'm nervous I'm sorry oh don't be
nervous I'm not good at this you know
you know that so we're good we're good
what's up okay all righty so um I'm been
married uh almost 44 years been with my
husband for 45 we got married very young
44.
44 years in August it will be you are
straight gangster congratulations not
really
well it hasn't been pretty good but
we've muddled through so you're still
still walking still walking all right so
what's up
well we're actually headed for divorce
because God deloney shut your mouth hey
I do that all the time I get all excited
about something and I cut somebody off
and then you say oh well now we're
getting divorced so sorry about that I'm
here celebrating you
yeah yeah that's just
anyways you know we've had our troubles
through the years but um
increasingly my husband's always been a
prepper we have a Y2K room if that tells
you anything and so um he's always been
kind of in that mode
which has actually come in handy
sometimes because we you know we have
extra food and stuff when you run out of
something but um
but in the last like probably five years
and more so in the last two years he's
just
um on his iPad following conspiracy
theories he's still working but he's
um you know he's just very I'd say
brainwashed to tell you the truth it's
quite bad and uh he's done stuff he's
handled our money our whole life which
I realized that probably wasn't very
wise I mean I've worked two most of our
marriage but I was the person that
handed my paycheck over and I get a
check per month and I have some credit
card use and I just didn't question
because
I believed he was putting our money in
savings and you know IRAs and I think he
used to be more conventional but now I
found out that he's put it all in gold
and silver and cryptocurrency and he
literally thinks the banks are crashing
and
um yeah just a lot of things he thinks
you know so are y'all getting divorced
is that happening
well what happened was I just so what
happened
you know the reason it came to that is I
just I was just we were just getting
more and more separate and you know he
was just watching these news things and
he kept saying you know anybody that got
a kova shot is going to die you know and
just I mean just these really bizarre
sure bizarre hold on answer my question
Dane are y'all getting divorced because
it's gonna it's gonna impact how I
answer this question
I don't know okay for sure that's when I
wrote a letter he kind of I wrote him a
letter say I'm just I don't I've been
watching you and Dave Ramsey probably
for the last six months and so I decided
to take a leap and just say you know I'm
really afraid about what's going on we
seem like more distance and I don't know
what's going on with our finances I'm
worried about things you're doing it
scares me
and either we need to talk about this
and get counseling or I don't know if we
need to separate or get a divorce but I
don't want to live prepping for the end
of the world and not enjoying life
anymore
good for you what was his response
well I said you know don't talk to me
when you're ready
um so he came the next night home from
work and
he didn't have anything written down but
instead of talking about that he brought
up
all the things I did in my past that
hurt our marriage you know and uh
and he said you're right we're not happy
we should just
split and I want we have a very complex
we have three properties you know a
business yada yada
he told me what he wanted and that he
was doing this this and this and this
and I mean I was really quite honestly
shocked and then I started asking him
well I need the finances you know I mean
literally we spent eight hours one day
unscrewing walls because there's gold
hidden in walls of all our properties
and it took us that long to go so I mean
I think I have piles of silver somewhere
you know and some in the walls but
um here's what needs to happen ASAP okay
let me just
um he doesn't want attorneys involved
and I don't that ship has sailed I have
I have four adult dollar you know it's
just very complicated it is yeah I'm
sorry none of this is complicated
okay
yeah you have a husband who's losing
touch in front of you with reality
yes and
um
he is he has left the iPad
um brain relationship where it's just
somebody getting transfixed by a screen
and now he is taking
increasingly erratic uh unsafe behaviors
when I say unsafe I'm not being dramatic
here he is putting you in exceptional
Financial Risk
yeah if something happens to him you are
sunk
because crypto and gold and silver are
three of the stupidest Investments you
can make
and
have people made money on crypto of
course
way more people lost
everything well he already admitted that
he lost a lot right and I don't know
what because he won't show me that and I
don't even understand that nor does he
understands
here's what he gets
he gets 48 hours to come clean with
where the finances are and where what is
and what's been spent and what the debt
ratios are and all that stuff I would
um
go to the credit bureaus and pull your
credit reports I Google it because
there's a Kelly can you find that
there's one site where you can pull your
credit report from all three
because you need to know what has been
leveraged against you
go ahead I did get a little bit of
information when this happened I did say
I need all these all our financials
within a week and for what I know he did
produce that
I mean we do he put all our IRAs and I
don't even know how he moved mine to
like a gold Trust Company and most of
the stuff those he's just taken out or
he's lost by making bad decisions
um but listen but listen but listen okay
okay well it's okay it's okay you've got
a person who's
not rational
who is doing things behind your back
yeah who is investing in things losing
tons of money
putting your family at risk
And yet when you say give me everything
you just trust everything you put in
front of you
I would not do that given the track
record here
okay and given the fact that he walked
in after you said here's what I need for
our relationship to stay whole and he
came in and said ah I'm out and here's
what I need here's what I'm gonna take
so you've heard me saying if it is yeah
this morning then I mean because it's
just this has been two months of just
horrific trying to sort it through and
just the trauma of it all and just the
sadness of it all too because I mean I
feel like I'm talking to a stranger it's
heartbreaking he wrote a note today
saying I'd like to work it out
but so I'm going to come up with a list
of all the things we have to do
immediately so I was going to take that
approach right so I mean I don't know if
it I don't know if I if I know this
brainwashing
well think
there can be but uh Kelly what did you
say that was
annualcreditreport.com okay so before
the day is over both of you have pulled
up an annualcreditreport.com
that tells you what you owe
any hidden debts that he has on that he
has piled up on his side any debts he's
taken out in your name with your social
security card number on your side it
lets you know what you owe
yeah then he's already given you an
account of an accounting of all the IRAs
that he's moved into gold
all of those go back
and I want you to call a smartvester pro
and those are certified
well I don't know well you don't even
know if anything
but I mean I've been married 44 years
yes but what he said was I want to work
it out
and so your terms of here's how what
working it out means is this
I need to know what this family owes you
and me combined I need to know where
every penny is I need to know every
penny you've lost
number four I'm cutting the internet off
to this house for 60 days
no internet access in this home
just you and me
number five we're going to marriage
counseling
and if you say no to any of these things
you were opting out of staying in this
marriage
because Diane I'm telling you right now
I've sat with too many widows who just
lost their husband who look at me with
this it's it's a very unique look
and they say something along the lines
of what do I do now because they don't
know where the money is they don't know
where the titles are they don't know
what's insured what's not insured they
don't know if their husband had wives
that they didn't know they don't know
anything
you are so exposed right now
and yeah that's why I'm I'm you can hear
it in my voice that's why I'm so adamant
the only way you get control back on
your life is if you grab it with both
hands
and I would not ask a person who is
detaching from reality right before your
eyes to be The Driver of building your
new life
you've got to take the reins and you
haven't had to do that for 44 years you
got to start now
yeah and I know that's terrifying I know
yeah
I have started and I do have a lot of
the information but I just don't know I
do have a lot of all the account numbers
I know the accountings of things I've
been able to get stuff I've gotten keys
I mean we have internet everywhere
though he can go anywhere we have
several properties that have it you know
I mean we have a lot of assets what I do
know is our houses all our properties
are free and clear okay that's awesome
so who didn't that you know that you
know of that I know of yeah you know yes
I don't normally know he but you don't
know if he took a HELOC out against one
of those properties and bought well he
300 000 for the crypto
he did pay back whatever he took out he
didn't do that I
because I saw I've been opening the mail
and uh because it's all in his name some
he gets shipped somewhere else I don't
know but uh Diane do you trust me that
when I'm telling you that you are
you are so exposed right now
because there you go
it's very
I'm known since I was 17 and
I'm a
I I feel like I'm
betraying him too when I
do these things you know I don't want to
get him in trouble
I don't know
I understand what you're saying I know
it is important let's listen you you're
right to have your heart broken
and you're right to miss your friend
and you're right to miss the main that
you built a life with
I mean if you include 44 years of
marriage plus knowing him you've known
him for half a century
I know right and so I I'm not telling
you to not be heartbroken and be so sad
that you're watching the person you've
spent the majority of your life with
just
fall through your hands like sand right
through your fingertips I get that yeah
and
there's a reality that it's actually
happening so you have to grieve this
this is hard and scary and my my deepest
prayer is that he circles up and goes oh
she's serious
um I I don't like living like this
either I don't know anybody in that
space in that mind frame that likes
being there and sometimes
they get lost to it but other times they
just need someone who loves them to flip
a light switch on and say whoa
you're about to lose everything all of
your money all the homes your wife your
daughters
because you are so down a rabbit hole of
Crazy Stupid news conspiracies and
everybody listening yes some of these
conspiracies into being true what are
you gonna do about it
nothing
so
pulling are all the banks gonna fail no
they're not
they're not and if they are let's say
they do if they do having gold stash in
your walls will not protect you from
what comes next
because your neighbors will come after
you for your water you're talking about
an apocalyptic movie you're not talking
about oh it's gonna pull the gold out so
we can buy cars and get to work on time
that will be over
so stop with
stop with the conspiracy nonsense
because you can listen to Diane this is
what's left in the wake
scared
spouses
scared kids
Diana is heartbreaking heartbreaking
heartbreaking heartbreaking I totally
get it I want you to stay on the line
I'm gonna send you a copy of own your
past change your future here's that book
here's the book is about dealing with
the scary stuff in the past and then
answering that scary question what are
we going to do now because you and your
husband are gonna have to build a new
relationship
or you're gonna have to build a new life
and all told you have to take
responsibility for what happens in your
life even though this guy's been walking
alongside you ride or die for 50 years
that appears to have changed
that means you gotta change and it's
going to be heartbreaking angry crying
rage all those things are right
but you got to take control take control
also you know what Diane stay on the
line I'm gonna send you
um Financial Peace University for a year
I work for Ramsey solutions for Dave
Ramsey and his Flagship product
Financial Peace University will walk you
and your husband through how to deal
with money
in a non-insane way
okay so hang on the line I'm gonna send
you both of those things that's on me
it's for free and I want you and your
husband to just say as a condition of us
staying together I want you to watch
these videos with me
okay Dave Ramsey's helped millions and
millions and millions and millions of
people become Millionaires and get out
of debt and take care of their family
Legacy through common sense not through
some internet IG down a YouTube rabbit
hole hack
love you Diane and I'm so sorry you're
going through this
so sorry